Hello, hello Pastor Randy Skeete. Hi,
how are you?
I am wonderful, thank you. Did you enjoy
your lunch? Oh, yes, yes, yes, I did.
Oh, thank you. Yes, thank you for taking
the time out for this Q&A session. You
know, this is something that my mother
and I really enjoy watching, you know,
after Sabbath afternoon.
I know it's also something that our
congregation also enjoys cuz it's
something that they are really looking
forward to.
>> All right.
At least one person said amen.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, I hope that the person that said
amen has a question that they want
answered.
We have the questions up there
somewhere.
>> Yes, the questions will be right on the
screen behind me. Okay. Yes, so you
ready to dive in?
>> Yes, Lord willing, yes.
>> Yes, you want to pray before we get
started?
>> of course. Our Father in heaven, we
thank you for the promise of James
chapter 1 verse 5. If any of you lack
wisdom, let him ask of God. Father, we
need that wisdom to answer your people
accurately, I pray. That you may be
glorified through the truth, and they
might be blessed. Bless the online
audience, dear God, in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen. Now, let's get started with
our first question.
The person asks, "When studying the
Bible, should I use a physical or a
digital one?" Both are fine. Okay. Uh
the digital one, it has a lot of
advantages. You may
consult uh docu- uh not documentaries,
uh commentaries and Bible dictionary
and, you know, uh things of that sort.
Whereas, this Bible here, the normal
traditional one, may not have all those
resources. When I'm in the pulpit, I use
one of these. I will not use a phone or
an iPad as a Bible. That's just me, I'm
not giving you a doctrine. But when I
study, yes, I use my iPad, I use my
iPhone, I use all these things because I
can access very quickly the writings of
Ellen White and other resources. So,
either one is fine for personal study,
yes. Mhm. I do [clears throat] think so,
too, Pastor, you know, when it's for
personal study Mhm. and I want to access
certain things quickly,
>> Mhm. you know, technology is rapidly
increasing, the amount of information is
increasing. We have access to all of
these information,
>> Mhm. and I think that's one of the
benefits of technology,
>> Okay. and we should be using them
properly as God intended.
>> Well, I think we've answered this first
question. Let's move on to another
question.
>> Mhm.
Oh, this person asks, "Could you please
explain the word blasphemy and
blaspheme?" Blaspheme generally falls
under two headings in the Bible. One,
claiming the power to forgive sins. In
Mark chapter 2 verse 5 to 7, when the
man was lowered through the roof into
the presence of Jesus Christ. In verse
5, we read, "When Jesus saw their faith,
he said unto the man, 'Son, thy sins be
forgiven thee.'" Now, there were some
scribes sitting by, and they said, "Why
doth this man thus speak blasphemies?
Who can forgive sins but God?" So, the
fact that Jesus forgave sins was to them
an act of blasphemy. Only God can
forgive sins. In John chapter 10 from
verse 30, Jesus said, "I and my Father
are one." Then the Jews took up stones
against to stone him. Jesus said unto
them, "For many good works have I shown
you of my Father. For which of these
works do you stone me?" They answered
him, "For good work we stone thee not,
but for blasphemy and because thou being
a man makest thyself God." So, when he
said, "I and my Father are one," he was
saying that they are equal, which was
true. The Jews regarded that as
blasphemy, which had to be punished by
death. And so, they took up stones to
stone him. Notice the Bible says,
"Again." So, Christ was always being
threatened because he never hesitated to
make the claim that he and his Father
were equal. So, blasphemy, claiming the
power to forgive sins,
and of course, claiming to be equal with
God. Okay, I think I think the person
who asked that question got a very
detailed explanation.
>> All right. Well, that's his
understanding. Now, let's move on to
another question. We'll be very rapidly.
Oh, how do I explain to those who
believe that the that Sunday is a
Sabbath? How do I explain that the
seventh day, the Saturday, is the
Sabbath? The Bible makes that very, very
clear, even in the Garden of Eden. If
[clears throat] you go to Genesis
chapter 2, we read verses 1 to 3 of
Genesis 2. Let me turn to God's people.
Thus the heavens and the earth were
finished and all the host of them.
And on the seventh day, God ended his
work which he had made. And he rested on
the seventh day from all his work which
he had made. And God blessed the seventh
day and sanctified it because that in it
he had rested from all his work which
God created and made. So, even in
Genesis 2, God tells us over and over,
the Sabbath is the seventh day. He
actually says it five times, although I
raise my finger three. But three times
you have seventh day, and twice you have
the pronoun it, which refers to seventh
day. Let's read it again. "And on the
seventh day, God ended his work which he
had made. And he rested on the seventh
day from all his work which he had made.
And God blessed the seventh day and
sanctified it because that in it he had
rested from all his work." So, five
times we're told the seventh day, the
seventh day, the seventh day.
Someone may ask, "How do I know which is
the seventh day?" It's very simple if
you're honest. On what day do Christians
celebrate Easter?
Not on Wednesday or Monday or Tuesday,
it is always celebrated on Sunday.
That's why it is called Easter Sunday.
It is the day on which Christ arose.
There's another so-called holy day that
comes before Easter Sunday, and that is
Good Friday.
The Sabbath of the Bible is the day
between Good Friday and Easter Sunday.
No one argues about which day is Good
Friday. No one argues about which day is
Easter Sunday. But people always argue
which day is the seventh day.
It's very simple if you're honest.
The day between Good Friday and Easter
Sunday is the Sabbath day. Amen. But
sometimes when Jesus preached, not even
Jesus could convince those who did not
want to be convinced.
Next question, I think. Yes. [laughter]
Next question, please.
Oh, what was nailed to the cross? That's
Well, Jesus was nailed to the cross.
>> [laughter]
>> And when Jesus died, all the ceremonial
uh sacrifices that pointed to him came
to an end. So, we read in 1 Corinthians
chapter 5 verse 7, "Christ our Passover
is crucified for us." All the
sacrifices, all the goings-on in the
sanctuary, the tabernacle, that
uh
economy, all pointed to Jesus.
When he died, they all came to an
effective end. It was no longer
necessary to have a Passover killing
animals or the feast of weeks or the
feast of the day of prep- the day of
trumpet, feast of trumpet. All of those
were fulfilled in Jesus Christ. And so,
what was nailed to the cross along with
Christ himself were all those ceremonies
that Christ himself fulfilled, you see,
not the 10 Commandments. Amen. The 10
Commandments existed before sin.
The Bible says the only way to sin is to
violate the law.
The Bible says Satan sinned.
He sinned before Adam was made.
The only way Satan sinned is because
there was a law. The 10 Commandments
existed before Adam and Eve were made.
Satan violated that law. He sinned. The
angels that followed him, the Bible
tells us in 2 Peter chapter 2 verse 4,
they sinned as well.
The law existed before sin. It exists
now. It'll exist after sin. So, Christ
cannot nail the law to the cross. He
would be nailing righteousness to the
cross because the law is righteous,
holy, spiritual, and good, and you do
not crucify that which is good and
spiritual righteous, except of course,
as Christ gave his life. The law, the 10
Commandments, were not nailed to the
cross. Amen. Thank you for that
explanation, Pastor. But sinners would
love to get rid of the law so they can
do whatever they want. That's Satan's
argument. Do whatever you want.
God's argument is, "Do what I say."
Mhm, "Do what I say." That's the only
way to live. Any other approach is
death.
Thank you, Pastor. Next question, if I
have a next question.
Oh, this is What is God's word? God's
word is whatever he says.
One of the features of the the Bible,
particularly the Old Testament, is how
often the writers say, "The word of the
Lord, the word of the Lord, the word of
the Lord, and God said, 'Thus saith the
Lord.'" The It was never "Thus saith me"
or "Thus saith she." "Thus saith the
Lord, the word of the Lord, and the Lord
spake." The Bible is God's word from
Genesis to Revelation.
All scripture is given by inspiration of
God and is profitable for doctrine, for
reproof, for correction, for instruction
in righteousness. People have to be
taught how to live righteously, and the
word of God is the textbook for that.
So, Genesis to Revelation constitute the
word of God. But as Seventh-day
Adventists, we have counsel from Ellen
White,
who was God's end-time servant. Her
writings are not anywhere like the
Bible, but they provide us the insights
that we would find nowhere else. And I
urge you familiarize yourselves with the
writings of Ellen White, please. Start
with Steps to Christ. Amen.
>> you go to Steps to Christ, start with
chapter 5 first, then read the rest of
the book.
What did I say?
Start with chapter 5.
Of which book? Steps to Christ.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you, pastor. Next
question. Mhm. How do you explain
Matthew chapter 7 27 verse 5 and Acts
chapter 1 verse 18? Okay, Matthew 27:5
tells us that Judas hanged himself.
Acts 1:18 tells us that he fell on the
ground and his insides were burst burst
open. There's no contradiction.
In Matthew, Matthew is emphasizing
the the the guilt that Judas had. He
felt so badly, he hanged himself.
Luke in Acts is emphasizing more divine
judgment against sin. And so Luke gives
a very horrible picture of what happened
to to to Judah. Obviously, after he
hanged himself, the body must have
fallen. Either the rope broke or the
branch broke and the body fell. It might
have fallen after several days hanging
on the on the tree. Remember, the Romans
would crucify people, they would be
hanging on the cross for days. So, it's
not strange to see someone hanging on a
rope for days. Clearly, the body fell
and the insides came on out. But they're
not two contradictory statements. The
Bible does not contradict itself. Amen.
>> If you find a contradiction in the
Bible, it exists in your mind, not in
the Bible.
>> [laughter]
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, pastor. Next
question.
Oh, should we play drums in the church?
>> play drums in church or anywhere else?
Uh that's an interesting question.
Thank you, pastor.
>> I don't recall where Ellen White makes a
statement. She said, "Just before the
close of probation,
there will be a loud form of worship
that will enter the church
with drums and other instruments making
a lot of noise." She calls it, I think,
bedlam, which is a lot of confusing
noises. She said, "This will occur in
the church. It will come back. It
happened in her day in Indiana. There
was something called the holy flesh
movement." And people believed once you
were saved, that's fine. You can do
anything with your body, fornication,
adultery, because you're already saved.
And the physical body is of no use. And
so part of that was loud noisy music.
And she sent the church sent two
observers to Indiana to to witness what
was happening. And then they reported to
Ellen White what they saw and she made
that statement just before the close of
probation, this loud noisy form of
worship will come back in the church.
And she identified drums as one of the
instruments. There is no sin in a drum.
A drum is not a sin. A guitar is not a
sin. An organ is not a sin.
>> [clears throat]
>> It is how they're played. But some
instruments have associations with them.
Oh. What do I mean by association? Which
what I call the law of association. Now,
there's a magazine in the United States
called Playboy. Ever heard of it? If you
haven't, that's fine. Anyway, it's
directed at men and in the middle of
that magazine always has a naked woman.
For decades the magazine has been
published. It has a logo.
The logo is what? The head of a rabbit.
So, the the the women are called bunnies
who work for Playboy. The head of a
rabbit. Now, God made rabbits on day
six.
Are you following me? Yes. But I would
not wear a t-shirt with the head of a
rabbit on it. Why? Because the rabbit is
known for Playboy, not for creation.
So, we have now association.
Are you with me? Asso- The association
is bad, so I'm not wearing a t-shirt
with the head of a rabbit because
Playboy has taken that over. Now, you
go, you watch any rock group. I'm not
recommending
but if you see them,
they're all up front with what?
Guitars and drums. Yes. All rock groups,
three or four of them playing guitars.
You come to church, there are three or
four men playing guitars. There's no sin
in the guitar, but the mind may be taken
in the wrong direction.
And so sometimes it's best to avoid
something. Even though the thing is not
in and of itself a sin, it's best to
avoid it because of what it may lead to.
Are you with me? Because of what it may
lead to, it's best to avoid certain
things. And I include drums among them.
But again, I say a drum is not a sin.
Nor is a guitar or a flute or a trumpet
or saxophone. It is a matter of how it
is played. But when Ellen White made her
statement, she identified drums.
You look at uh tribal practices, almost
all cultures, the drum is present. Not a
saxophone or an organ or piano. The drum
is fundamental to heathen worship and uh
practices. And so I recommend, with all
humility, avoiding the drums. Okay.
Very wonderful insight, pastor. Thank
you. Let's move on to another question.
Oh, this is one of my friend's question.
My friend asked me to write this
question. He said, "Can I choose to be a
pastor and know that it is God that
calls me to be a pastor?"
You can choose to be a pastor, yes. It
doesn't mean God called you. Mhm. The
calling of God is expressed in a in in a
few ways. You feel a tremendous
conviction, a burden, a heavy burden on
you. I've always known as a child I
should preach. Whatever else I did, I
must preach. I've always known that.
Can't get away from it.
Also, what do the members of the church
see in you? Mhm.
Because they have gifts that you may not
have. One gift the church must have is
discernment. What do the members see in
you? What do your parents see in you?
What are people telling you that you
seem best suited to do? It's not just I
want to be a pastor because I can get up
in the pulpit and tell the church what
to do. A pulpit is not a crown uh
a throne from which you rule a kingdom
called the church. And so you ask God,
Psalm 32:8, "I will instruct thee and
teach thee in the way which thou shalt
go. I will guide you with mine eye." You
ask God, Psalm 25:4,
"Show me thy ways, O Lord. Teach me thy
paths. Lead me in thy truth." You ask
God, Jeremiah 33:3,
"Call unto me and I will answer thee and
show thee." And so you ask God and then
you ask yourself, "Do I like giving
Bible studies? Do I like counseling
people?" It is not just stand in a
pulpit for 45 minutes on Sabbath and
perform. There's a lot more to being a
pastor than that. That's a minor part of
being a pastor. Most of a pastor's work
is caring for the sheep one-on-one,
visiting the members, going to the
hospital, going to the funeral, going to
the graduation, going to the police
station to get that boy who was
arrested. All of that is the pastor's
work, not just getting up in the pulpit
and having people clap when you say
something. And so you you you think you
ought to be a pastor, you take it to
God. Father, put a conviction on my
heart.
Open the way for me. You ask him. And
then you ask people, "What do you
observe in me?"
You see? The Bible says, "If a man
desire the office of a bishop, he
desires a good thing." That's what Paul
writes, 1 Timothy chapter 3:1. So, it's
a good work to do. But when you
understand what that work involves, you
may change your mind. A good pastor is a
hard-working man. Amen. Are you with me?
Amen.
>> not just show up to preach and give
announcements. A good pastor is a
hard-working man who is on duty 24 hours
a day.
That's right. Someone dies in your
family, you call the pastor 12:00 at
night, he can't tell you, "Well, I am
playing with my wife."
He can't tell you that. "Oh, I'm sorry,
I'll be right there." A pastor is on
duty 24 hours a day. Seven days.
>> So, think twice before you decide, "I
want to be a pastor." You can serve God
without being a pastor. You can preach
without being a pastor. You can have
cruises without being a pastor. Amen.
Amen. Well, Roy, I hope your question is
answered. Let's move on to another one.
>> Mhm.
It says, "Please Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. This
[clears throat] is a Okay.
>> "Please clarify. This one seems like a
personal one. Why some people preach
that salvation is based on what you
eat?" Well,
let's express that differently.
If you disobey God, you cannot be saved.
Amen. Now, God has said clearly, "Don't
eat certain things." That's right. If
you high-handedly and stubbornly and
flagrantly and deliberately and
purposefully eat what God tells you do
not eat, you're putting your feet on the
path to destruction. Amen. Obedience
qualifies no one for heaven, it
qualifies you for hell. So, while I
won't use the expression "salvation is
based on what you eat," a disobedient
person cannot be saved.
>> Amen.
>> And the Bible is clear, there are some
meats we should not eat. Pork and crabs
and pastor.
>> snails and slugs and whatever else. We
should not eat those things and lizards
and spiders. If you eat them, you have
disobeyed God and that is what takes you
to hell, not the slug or the spider,
your disobedience to God. Amen.
>> Mhm. So, yes, how you eat can affect
your salvation. How you dress, the Bible
says dress modestly with shamefacedness
and sobriety.
Not to show off, but to look like a
child of God. You decide to look like
the world, you've disobeyed God. You're
destroyed not because of the length or
shortness of your skirt, because you
disobeyed God's word consistently and
never repented.
Amen.
>> Mhm.
You can't call yourself a child of God
and eat whatever you like.
Because we're told in 1 Corinthians
6:19-20,
"You're not your own. Say that
>> You're bought with a price.
Your body is the dwelling of the Holy
Ghost. If the Holy Ghost lives here, I'm
not putting alcohol in it. If the Holy
Ghost lives here, I'm not putting smoke
in the dwelling place of the Holy Spirit
or drugs. Are you with me? I'm not doing
that. It's the Holy Ghost residence.
Amen.
So, be careful what you eat and drink
and how you dress because all of those
expressions of your relationship with
God.
Amen. When God God told Moses
instructions about making clothes for
Aaron the high priest.
In Exodus 28 verse two, the Bible says,
God told Moses, "And thou shalt make
holy garments for Aaron for glory and
for beauty."
Holy garments for glory and for beauty.
Glory first. In other words, when Aaron
dresses, he should look like
the heavenly priest himself.
Then beauty comes second.
We reverse that.
We shop for beauty
and completely forget glory.
How many times have you bought a dress
thinking, "I this will glorify God."
Don't answer me. Or a suit for that
matter.
We must think of God. You cannot think
of God too often. Am I looking like a
child of God dressed this way? Was I
thinking of God when I made that
purchase with God's money?
And so, we have to
be careful how we dress, how we eat.
Mhm. How we play.
Either you're a child of God or you're
not.
You see, heaven and earth are two
opposites.
The lifestyle of the earth
is precisely the opposite of the
lifestyle in heaven.
Are you with me? Yes. And so, the Bible
says, "Ye adulterers and adulteresses,
know ye not or do you not know that
friendship of the world is enmity with
God. Whosoever therefore will be a
friend of the world is the enemy of
God."
And we establish friendships with the
world, friendships with the world by the
way we eat, the way we dress, the things
we wear, the way we speak, you know, the
recreations we engage in. All of that
mark us as friends of the world, which
means enemies of God even though we are
in church. Uh-huh. The people who said,
"Crucify him." were enemies of Christ,
but they went to church more often than
Jesus.
Next question. Yes, next question. Thank
you, pastor.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh-oh. If I was baptized at another
church, I guess they mean denomination,
should I be rebaptized in this one?
In Acts chapter 19, the Apostle Paul met
12 disciples
who had never heard of the Holy Spirit.
So, Paul said to them, "Unto what were
you baptized?" Acts 19 verse three.
And they said, "John's baptism."
Paul said, "John verily baptized with
baptism of repentance saying that they
should believe on him should to come
after him, which is Jesus." The Bible
says when they heard that, they were
baptized in the name of Jesus Christ.
They were rebaptized having learned
significant information.
When someone comes to this church,
they'll learn things you've never heard
before.
Significant information. And if that
person truly wants to make a change,
that person will get baptized. Now, the
church does have something called
profession of faith where you state, "I
agree. I agree." You just say it and the
baptism is not done, but that is for
extreme circumstances.
It is not the standard practice.
The standard practice is be baptized
into the body of God's people. So, yes,
be rebaptized. There are some Adventists
who need to be rebaptized. Oh, mercy.
Not coming from another church, coming
from an Adventist church who need to be
rebaptized because they are as far from
God as you can get, but in the church.
Mercy. You look uncomfortable. Let me
leave that alone.
I've got another question.
>> Yes, next question.
Oh, is it wrong, you know, when we have
potluck? Is it wrong to eat in the
church building or on the church
compound?
>> We must respect the place of worship.
We have to respect On the other hand,
God understands when this is all we
have.
Now, if you were
let's say you remember of a little
church. It has one room church.
You have a potluck. You usually eat
outside. A thunderstorm comes.
What do you do?
You have to eat inside.
But eat inside remembering this is an
unusual situation and you have to behave
yourself.
Because the the house of worship to God
is a sacred place.
Whether it's under tree or building or
mansion, it is sacred. Why? It is the
place of God's uh
ceremonial presence. And so, we avoid
having
lunch inside the church.
Because
when you're having lunch, we regard that
as not a spiritual event. Oh, my.
Let me say that again.
This morning at 11:00, we call it divine
service. Yes.
>> We don't have divine potlucks. Are you
with me?
We have divine service. So, we behave
one way in the divine service. We behave
another way in the potluck even though
it is still the Sabbath.
Ah.
We dress one way for the divine service.
We dress another way for AY. Yes. But
the Sabbath is holy from sunset to
sunset. Yes. So, all I'm saying to you
is if you have to use the place of
worship under extreme circumstances, be
careful how you conduct yourself in the
house of God.
But as a normal way of life, don't eat
in God's church. Amen.
>> Find some other place to do that.
Amen. All right, next we'll move on to
another question.
Oh, which parent This is a family
question. Should initiate family worship
and discipline bad behavior in children?
I think that's a good one. The one in
charge of discipline is the father.
He is the main disciplinarian. Let me
say the main.
He may be at work and the mother has to
apply some discipline, but the mother
should be the one to whom the children
whom the children see as whom they can
go to, put their head on their lap, on
their tenderness. When anything
in the line of punishment has to be
done, the father should do that even
though he has to be a loving father. But
the father, according to Ellen White, is
the disciplinarian of the house. And so,
Paul tells us you want to be a church
leader, you must rule your house and
your children well.
You must rule and have them in
subjection with all gravity. The Bible
speaks of the man, "You rule your
house." The word rule is not good
because modern men may misunderstand
that, but you must be the head of your
home. Amen.
>> And you're the main disciplinarian. Mhm.
And you should initiate worship.
Because you're the priest of the home.
Are you with me? Yes. The man is the
head of the home.
I never said he's the dictator of the
home. I said he's the head of the home.
And his greatest blessing is an
intelligent wife
to whom he can listen. Somebody say
amen. Amen. All right. And so, but he
takes leads out in worship and he is the
disciplinarian of the home.
Disciplinarian may sound harsh, but he's
the one who keeps order mainly and
chiefly.
Pastor, I have a counter question. What
about single parent home, single mother
homes? Well, the mother has to do it.
Mother has to take up responsibility.
Yes, she has to do it.
And there are many single homes.
And many of the ladies do a very good
job. Amen. But you cannot beat God's
system.
God's system is a husband, a wife, the
children. That is God's system. It's
always best.
But if circumstances alter that, then we
do the best we can under the
circumstances in which we find
ourselves. And I say again, many single
parents have done an outstanding job in
bringing up their children and keeping
them under the shadow of the wing of
Jesus Christ. Amen. Amen. Thank you,
pastor. Moving on to another question.
Oh.
This person wants to know, is it
possible to sense evil? Yes.
One of the gifts of the church is the
gift of discernment.
Amen. I'm not sure if the church has it
as much as it should, [snorts]
>> [laughter]
>> but there must be people in the church
who can discern.
You can sense without any scientific
evidence.
For instance,
here's a mother.
Her daughter comes to her and says,
"Mommy, I'm bringing a
a son." The son says, "Mommy, I'm
bringing my girlfriend for you to meet
her."
And the boy brings this girl home.
And the mother is the one to look her
over, not the father, the mother mainly
because woman to woman.
And something tells that mother
>> [clears throat]
>> Now, she has no scientific proof, but
being a mother and having raised that
boy, she feels she senses something is
not right about that woman.
Or
her daughter brings home a boy.
Uh Mommy and Daddy, meet my boyfriend.
The father now
looks at him.
And the father says, "Uh-uh.
There's something not right about this
boy."
He has no proof from a scientific
laboratory, but he just realizes as a
parent with the power of discernment,
something is not right.
And so, the church should have
discernment.
Discernment doesn't mean you have all
the details. It just means something is
not right. We're moving in the wrong
direction. Stop. Or whatever else. Yes,
you should be able to sense
evil.
Or you're heading in the wrong
direction.
Or disaster is on the way.
The church must be able to sense that.
This is not uh extrasensory perception.
this is the Holy Spirit working on the
mind. Amen. Mhm.
Remember when God called Samuel?
He called him three times.
The fourth time, the Bible says Eli
perceived
the Lord had called the child.
He did not perceive that the first,
second, or third time. The fourth time,
it finally clicked, this is God calling.
Uh-huh. So, he perceived
he sensed God was calling Samuel. Amen.
Next question. Next question.
As a newly wed new couple, what advice
would you give to bless us with for a
successful marriage? Keep God in the
middle.
The Bible says, "I am the way, the
truth, and the life.
No man cometh unto the Father but by
me." So, Jesus is the mediator between
God and the sinner.
Jesus must be between the husband and
the wife. Not to separate them, but to
connect them. Amen. You understand? So,
Jesus holds the husband's hand, holds
the wife's hands, and in Jesus they're
connected.
Put God in the middle.
Amen. Let him be your focal point.
Talk to him often
and talk to each other. Amen.
>> And whatever the problems may be.
Marriage is a blessing,
but it also has a lot of stresses.
If you don't believe me, ask Abraham and
Sarah.
If you don't believe them, ask Isaac and
Rebecca.
And if you don't believe them, ask Jacob
and Rachel. They had some serious
problems and they were brought together
by God. Amen. Are you with me? And if
you still don't believe them, ask Jesus
and his wife, the church. And Jesus will
tell you all the headaches that woman
has given him. And so, marriage is good,
but it is stressful.
And the one thing you absolutely have
must have is God brought us together.
Amen.
>> And once you can stand on that rock, you
can handle any stress. Amen. Mhm. You
know, I have heard pastor that the
closer the couple gets to God Uh-huh.
they get to each other.
>> course, automatic. Mhm.
Amen to that. [clears throat] Mhm. Let's
move on to another question.
Oh, I guess this is part of a previous
question. Why are we not to eat certain
meats?
And which part of the Bible says so?
>> Leviticus 11.
The whole chapter? Tells us what not to
eat. Some things not to eat. Now, God
doesn't tell us why you shouldn't eat
the pig. What is chemically wrong with
the pig? No. God said,
"Don't eat it."
He said, "It's unclean to you." You read
the Leviticus 11, the first 10 or so
verses, "It's unclean to you.
It's unclean to you. It's unclean to
you. If you're my child, some things are
unclean to you." Over and over we have,
"It's unclean to you. It's unclean to
you." And so, God has forbidden us to
eat animals that are not cloven-footed
and that don't chew the cud.
Um
fish in the sea must have scales and
fins.
And those are the the the identifying
marks of meats that are edible or
suitable for the child of God, but
we have to go one step higher and give
up meat altogether.
Ah.
Let me uh
I think you have to explain that one,
pastor.
You promise not to call the police?
No. Okay, let me tell you why.
Let me pray again. Father,
as we talk to your people, give us
wisdom, wisdom, wisdom, dear God. In the
name of Jesus Christ I pray. Amen.
The one Bible text that is the
foundation of the Seventh-day Adventist
Church
is Daniel 8:14.
And he said unto me,
"Unto 2,300
and 300 days, then shall the sanctuary
be cleansed." That cleansing took place
every year in the Old Testament on the
10th day of the seventh month, which
equates to October 22
in a in the calendar now.
Adventists worked out prophecy
and concluded correctly
that the fulfillment of that ceremony
was 1844, October 22, when Jesus Christ
began the work of cleansing in the most
holy place, which is above because the
Bible tells us there's a sanctuary
above, which was the original on which
the earthly one was based.
Are you following me?
Let me say it again.
God told Moses, "Build a sanctuary."
There was an outer court, holy place,
most holy place, different articles of
furniture, and a fence all around.
The Bible tells us there's a sanctuary
in heaven built by God, not by man.
Are you with me? All right, now, on the
Day of Atonement, October 22, 1844,
Jesus moved from the holy place to the
most holy and began a work of cleansing
and of judgment or we call
investigation. Now,
on in the earthly sanctuary, the priest
only went into the most holy place once
a year.
For 359 days, because the Jewish year
has 360 days. For 359,
the priest functioned in the holy place.
Sometimes when a sacrifice was brought,
he would take a piece of the sacrifice
and eat it in the holy place as a means
of identifying with the sinner because
Jesus identifies with us. Let me say it
again. Sometimes the priest would take
meat into the holy place and consume it
as a way of the priest identifying with
the sinner, Jesus identifying with us.
Amen. On the Day of Atonement, no meat
was taken into the most holy place.
None at all, just the blood of Christ.
We are now antitypically in the great
day of atonement,
where no meat was brought into the most
holy place.
And so, we should be aware that avoiding
meat should be a matter of serious
consideration for us.
I'll tell you something else.
Before there was sin, the diet was
plants.
In the new world to come, Revelation 22,
the diet will be the tree of life,
fruits and whatever else.
In between perfect Eden and Eden
restored, we have sin.
Meat-eating is the result
of sin.
Plant-based diet
is the result of a sinless environment.
Amen. Are you with me?
A plant-based diet will be in heaven
again when it is sinless. Meat-eating is
the result of sin.
It's like divorce.
God intended all married people to stay
together,
but Moses said because of Jesus said,
"Because of the hardness of your heart,
Moses suffered you to divorce." Divorce
is a result of sin. Even though some
people have good reason, it is still the
result of sin. So, what we have up here,
we have the ideal diet that's plants.
Down here, we have what is allowed,
that's meat. Uh-huh.
As a people who strive for the best,
we can't stay here.
We have to strive for what's ideal.
Because when you send your children to
school, you don't want them to get
grades that are down here.
You want them to get grades that are up
here.
With respect to meat,
our diet, meat-eating is down here. A
plant-based diet is up here. Amen.
I hear three amens.
Now, let me tell you this. Ellen White
says,
"The health reform
is progressive.
You don't change your eating habits
overnight.
Because one of the most difficult things
to change is eating habit.
There are companies, at least United
States, they do uh
uh tests on children to see what they
like.
And then they produce those things in
the restaurants.
So, the child grows up eating a certain
way. When the child becomes an adult, it
is hard to break away from that kind of
eating.
Breaking away from meat is not easy.
But if it's your desire,
God will help you.
Now, it you need to understand Ellen
White tells us that most cancers and
tumors are caused by consuming flesh.
Now, you read that, you ought to
tremble. Most cancers and tumors are
caused by eating flesh.
She said, "Eating flesh stirs up the the
lower passions."
So, you do yourself a favor physically
and morally
by avoiding or cutting out cutting down
or avoiding completely the consumption
of flesh. Now, she also says there may
be some countries where it's not
practical to have a totally plant-based
diet. In that case, she makes
exceptions.
Because Ellen White was very
intelligent, she realized what applied
to the United States may not fit some
country in the middle of Pacific.
So, she said, "In some countries, it may
not be possible to have that kind of
diet.
So, let them do the best they can with
fish or whatever they have. But
generally, she says, we ought to do all
we can
to avoid eating dead animals."
All right. All right, let's move on to
another question.
>> Mhm.
By the way,
the healthier your mind is, the better
you understand the word of God.
Are you with me? The better your mind,
the the better your health, the better
you understand the word of God. If you
look at the American Heart Association,
the American Cancer Association, or
whatever association, one of the
recommendations they always give is
either cut out meat completely or cut it
back drastically. And they are not
religious organizations.
Okay, I'm done with that. And this
question I'm I'm being told is our final
question which makes this Q&A very
short. Well, that's fine. That's fine.
It says, "How can I allow God to take
full control of my life?" You surrender
your life to him by telling him.
The world began by God saying something.
Let there be light.
We're introduced to God who said
something. The Bible tells us in Romans
chapter 10 verse 9, "If thou shalt
confess with thy mouth
the Lord Jesus
and shall believe in thy heart that God
has raised him from the dead, thou shalt
be saved." There must be something that
is spoken.
When Jesus cast out demons, he didn't
think about it.
He spoke it.
When he raised Lazarus, he spoke it.
When he forgave sins, he spoke it. When
he stilled the waves, he spoke it. Now,
being God, he could have thought it.
But God loves to talk.
And so you tell God, "Father, I
surrender my life to you. Every aspect
of my life, financial, professional,
educational, uh family, recreational, I
surrender every area of my life to your
control."
You make that surrender every day.
And then you check the textbook to see
how he would have you live. This is
God's manual for how to. It's a how-to
manual. How to set up a screen, how to
set up online streaming, how to do this.
This is God's how-to manual for the
whole world. But you say to God, you
tell him, "Father, I surrender my life,
every area of my life, to your control
and you make that surrender every single
day. It only takes 5 to 10 seconds.
That's all." Amen.
>> You must keep doing it. Otherwise says,
"Genuine conversion is needed, not once
in years, but daily."
Next question. Oh,
Pastor, I'm being told that that's all
they have collected.
>> enough. Okay. Well, [laughter] well,
well, well, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. There are some people who wanted
to ask questions, but they closed the
door on them.
>> [clears throat]
>> yeah, well, we have to obey.
>> [laughter]
>> There's something called temperance.
Yes. You can't go too far in anything.
So, this is enough for now. People have
to think of what they heard.
But Ray is my boss, so I'm the pastor,
so whatever they say, the case is
closed.
We'll take a few. Case closed.
>> Yes. Let's take a few.
>> Dr. Ray, you tell us what a few is and
we'll follow you.
A hundred? Okay. [laughter]
All right.
>> Okay. Pray for Ray.
All right, who has a question?
I know someone
>> Oh, there's a nice person right back
here. Right back there.
>> [snorts]
>> Give him a mic, please.
Good evening, Pastor.
>> Good evening, my brother.
I just had a question, well, not really
a question, but just more explanation
more in-depth towards um well, I don't
eat certain type of meats either, right?
But um
could you explain Romans 14, why it said
why does it say um if a man what doesn't
goes into a man or defiles a man or
something? Can you explain that for me,
please?
Okay, that's uh you can read it in
Matthew, I think, 20 Matthew 15 and Mark
chapter 7. Um
that which cometh out of a man, that
defileth the man. Now,
eating pork pork is not what kills you.
It is disobedience. Are you following
me?
Before you've eaten the pork, taken it
inside, something has come out of you
and that is disobedience. You have
decided to disobey God. So, it is not
the physical pork entering you that
defiles you. It is your disobedience.
So, that's a good point that brother Ray
raised. What goes into you doesn't
defile you.
Go to Mark chapter 7. Mark 7.
Yes, my good brother, are you abandoning
me?
Okay.
Just checking.
Okay. All right. Do we have Mark chapter
7?
It's not on the screen, so you have to
open your Bible.
Who has it?
Nobody has Mark chapter 7.
Mark is Gospel chapter 2.
Chapter 7
verse 20.
Someone read out loud.
He said, "That which
Yes.
Now, he said, "That which cometh out of
the man Let me stand up. I don't
like to sit and talk. That which cometh
out of the man,
that defileth the man." Now, Jesus gives
some examples of what comes out of us
that defiles us. Someone read verse 21.
"For from within out of the heart of man
proceed evil thoughts come on adulteries
come on fornication uh-huh murders come
on thefts covetousness wickedness deceit
uh-huh
deceitfulness an evil eye
pride blasphemy Yes, now Jesus says that
is what defiles a person.
When you decide to eat some meat, pork
or shellfish,
that's going from the outside in.
Follow me closely. That is going from
the outside in.
That's not what causes the problem.
What causes the problem is the act of
disobedience that went from the inside
out.
You're not getting it. Let me try again.
Huh?
You got it?
No, you don't have it.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, okay.
It's very important. When you understand
that, you'll understand why Jesus could
take our sins and still remain sinless.
Go to Leviticus 1. Go to Leviticus 1
quickly.
Leviticus 1.
>> [clears throat]
>> This is a very important question, by
the way.
I know my brother didn't mean to have
all of that come in, but I'm glad he
asked that question.
What defiles you?
Are you Leviticus 1?
Read with me. "And the Lord called unto
Moses and spake unto him out of the
tabernacle of the congregation, saying,
'Speak unto the children of Israel and
say unto them, if any man of you bring
an offering unto the Lord, you shall
bring your offering of the cattle, even
of the herd and of the flock.' Come on.
'If his offering be a burnt sacrifice of
the herd, let him offer a male without
blemish. He shall offer it of his own
voluntary will at the door of the
tabernacle of the congregation before
the Lord." Now, listen to verse 4.
"And he shall put his hand upon the head
of the burnt offering. And it shall be
accepted for him to make atonement for
him." Pause.
What is meant by put his hand on the
head?
Go to Leviticus 16.
This is the day of atonement now in this
chapter. Leviticus 16. My online
friends, I hope you're with us.
Welcome, welcome. I forgot I did not
welcome you. I'm so sorry. Welcome to
this Q&A
in San Hill, Belize. Do you have
Leviticus 16? Yes, Pastor.
>> You read from verse 20.
Read with me. "And when he hath made an
end of reconciling the holy place and
the tabernacle of the congregation and
the altar, he shall bring the live
goat." Now, carefully, "And Aaron shall
do what? Lay both his hands upon the
head of the live goat and confess over
him all the what? Iniquities of the
children of Israel and all the
transgressions and all their sins."
Stop. Putting your hand on the head of
the animal symbolizes confessing.
So, the sin goes from you
to the animal, symbolically. Now, let's
go back to Leviticus 1. We read verse 4.
This, by the way, is the burnt offering,
the most fundamental offering in the
Bible, the most basic. This is what
Christ offered on Calvary. This is what
Noah offered when he came out of the
ark. This is what God called Abraham to
offer Isaac as a burnt offering. That
offering is the only one where
everything was burnt except the skin.
The only one consumed totally was the
burnt offering. It arose to God as a
sweet-smelling savor. Verse 4, Leviticus
1, "And he shall put his hand upon the
head of the burnt offering. And it shall
be accepted for him to make atonement
for him." So, when the sinner put his
hand on the head of the animal, what was
he doing? Come on, tell me.
Come on. We we read it in Leviticus 16.
What was he doing? Confessing and
transferring his sins symbolically from
himself to the animal. I say
symbolically because no animal can save
you. But it's this way to get them to
understand that the blood of Christ to
come would be the thing that saves them.
Now,
listen to me carefully.
The animal represents whom?
Jesus. Jesus.
The sinner is the sinner.
When the sinner confesses, in what
direction is sin going?
From the inside out to the animal.
But the Bible says,
"What comes from without doesn't condemn
you."
Concentrate.
Jesus said,
"That which cometh out of a man,
that defileth the man."
When the man confesses a sin over the
animal, the sin goes from the animal to
the man, symbolically.
From the from the man to the animal. It
does not make the animal unclean.
Because you can't have of unclean
sacrifice.
So, the animal takes the sin and remains
sinless.
The same way Jesus takes our sins and
remains sinless. Why? Because when he
takes our sins, they travel from the
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. They
travel from the Yes, in
Ah, you're not with me.
>> [laughter]
>> I
You're making me work overtime.
Listen to me carefully. Here is Jesus.
Is that clear?
Here's a big sinner, that's me. Don't
say amen.
And uh
>> [laughter]
>> I confess my sins, huh? Jesus takes my
sins. They go from the outside into
Jesus. But Jesus said, "It's not what
goes from the outside in that defiles
you, it's what comes from the inside
out."
And no sin ever came from Jesus.
So, he can take our sins and remain
sinless because nothing ever came out of
him that wasn't clean.
Are you with me?
You're thinking?
And so, when you eat pork
or whatever else God tells you don't
eat,
it's not the pork coming in.
It's your decision going out
to disobey God.
That's where the sin lies.
You have decided
to tell God,
"Forget you, I'll do what I want."
That's the sin.
Remember Genesis 1:31? And God saw
everything that he had made, and behold,
it was very good. Where God made the pig
for their own purpose.
Are you with me? God made the alligator
for its own purpose. There was not
There's nothing wrong with a pig.
By the way, a pig is unclean, so is a
dog, but we hug the dog, we kiss the
dog.
We don't kiss the pig.
Nobody's listening to me.
The pig is as unclean as the dog.
But we kiss the dog.
And the dog sleeps in a bed with us.
And we curse the pig.
Are you listening to me?
If you kiss a dog, we'll kiss the pig,
too.
Okay.
Obey God.
If God tells you
don't eat a rab- a crab,
don't eat it.
And your reason for not eating it is
simply this, God said, "Don't eat it."
And I do not demand an explanation from
God
because he knows what he's doing.
Don't eat it, I don't eat it.
Simple as that.
All right, somebody else. Pastor, I
Your pastor gave me a question from an
online audience.
And I have to word this very carefully.
They asked,
"When
will the sealing of God's children start
and end?" We have no date.
There's no date. All right, and they had
But the sealing is going on now.
Mhm. Yes.
Go on. And they asked, "How long will
the plagues last?" We don't know how
long the plagues will last. They won't
last long.
L Y tells us it will be so terrible,
it'll be brief. Because the plagues
represent a part of the wrath of God
poured out without mixture.
Are you following me? Go to Revelation
14. Let me show you what I mean.
Revelation 14, let's read from verse 9.
We're looking at the third angel's
message, which is the very at the very
foundation of Adventism. Revelation 14,
reading from verse 9.
Are you Oh, here we go.
>> [laughter]
>> I thought the only questions coming up
there. All right, let's pray again. Our
Father in heaven, as we try to answer
questions, speak through me clearly and
help me to slow down. In Jesus' name I
pray. Amen. And the third angel followed
them saying with a loud voice, "If any
man worship the beast and his image and
receive his mark in his forehead or in
his hand,
same shall drink of the wine of the
wrath of God, which is poured out
without mixture into the cup of his
indignation. And he shall be tormented
with fire and brimstone in the presence
of the holy angel and in the presence of
the lamb." Now, when will that
tormenting with fire take place? Not
when Jesus comes the second time.
But the seven last plagues, they come
just before Jesus comes, which means the
full wrath of God combines the seven
last plagues and what Jesus does at the
end of the thousand years when he uses
fire to purify the world. All of that
represents the wrath of God without
mixture. Now, in order to survive the
seven last plagues, we have to be sealed
because they come after probation
closes.
Are you with me?
They are God's part of God's wrath, and
God does not pour out his wrath while
probation still lingers.
So, when probation closes and everyone
is sealed, we have no date.
Then
the seven last plagues will come,
affect the whole world.
They won't last long because it'll be
intense. The world will be in turmoil.
You should conduct or have someone come
conduct a prophecy seminar for you. But
we have no date for when the sealing
begins, but surely the sealing has been
going on.
Because God People die every day.
And if you die, you have to be died You
have to die sealed or unsealed.
You die unsealed, you're not saved.
So, at an individual level, sealing is
going on.
Make sure you're sealed before you put
your head on that pillow tonight
by having all sins confessed. There is
no date for when the sealing begins.
There is no date, but there are signs
that will tell us. Because when we see
the plagues begin to fall, we know
probation closed.
Mhm.
All right, next question. Yes, this one
comes from an audience. This Yes, people
asked this one last night. This asked,
"We know that on the sixth day God
created animals, and he created Adam."
But Adam was tasked with naming the
animals.
But Eve was created after that. So, he
asked, "On what day what time frame was
Eve created?"
Eve and Adam were made on the same day.
They were made on the sixth day because
God ended everything on the seventh, he
was done. He didn't do work on the
seventh. So, all of that, the creation
of Adam, the animals, and Eve, all took
place on the sixth day. Yes. Yes, same
day.
Oh. You see, God did it by his word.
Amen. His word, he said, "Let there be
light." The light came. Let there be a
firmament, bam, by his word. So, God
doesn't need a lot of time to say, "Let
there be light." It just comes.
So, all on the same day.
Everything will happen on the same day.
All right.
>> Eve, Adam, the animals.
Amen. Well, the animals were made all in
the you know, the fish were made on day
five, the birds on day five, and the
land animals on day six. Yes, so. Yeah,
land animals, Adam and Eve, six. All
right. Now, we can throw it over to
whoever wants to ask a question.
>> Yes, right over here.
Could you please um
explain Hebrews chapter 1, verses 1 to
3?
Cuz I wonder if prophets still exist
today because it says
>> You wonder what? If prophets still exist
today. Because it says in days gone by,
God used to speak to men through
prophets. But in these latter days, it
says he speaks to men through his son.
So, could you explain Hebrews 1, 2, and
3 for me? Chapter 1, verses 1 to 3.
Okay.
Uh is that out of there? God, who at
sundry times and in diverse manners
spake in time past unto the fathers by
the prophets, hath in these last days
spoken to us by his son. That doesn't
mean he does not use prophets because
Jesus came, but Jesus represented the
highest form of God's communication with
us. But even in the days of Jesus, there
were prophets on the earth. John the
Baptist was a prophet while Christ was
on the earth. Philip had four daughters
who were prophetesses while during the
days of Acts. So, there were prophets on
the earth even while Jesus Christ was on
the earth. But God's highest form of
expression to us is through Jesus
Christ, who ultimately is his word. So,
yes, the gift of prophecy has not ended.
Romans chapter 12, verse 8 to 10, we
have the gift of prophecy.
The last time it was manifested for us
was in the life of Ellen White, who
lived from 18-1827
to 1915, 88 years, and she served the
church 70.
That's the last time the church
recognized prophet among God's people.
But the gift of prophecy has not yet
ceased. So, God can decide to send us
another one.
We don't know.
But the gifts will end
when probation ends, there's no longer
need for that gift.
Because the gifts are for the edifying
of the church.
Say it again.
Okay, here's the question. Why were
there more prophets then than now? Well,
now we have the Old Testament.
We have the New Testament. We have God's
revealed will. We don't have this great
need for all these prophets. Back then,
there was no Old Testament, there was no
New Testament, so God spoke to prophets.
He gave them dreams. He gave them
visions. But now, we have the word of
God. We don't need prophets as they did
back then.
Pastor, I have I received three
questions from our audience.
I was I'll read this one that's on
paper. It says, "Is it right for the
pastor to baptize with jewelry?"
I well, I'm not sure how they want that
worded. Is it right for the pastor to
baptize someone wearing jewelry? I think
that's the question they asked. asking.
Or or
>> pastor himself is wearing it, what does
what does the person
>> Really if the pastor is wearing jewelry,
that's that's already [laughter] Okay.
That's what it sounds like. Should a
pastor wearing jewelry conduct baptism?
Uh the Adventist church discourages the
wearing of jewelry.
And that's based on uh 1 Timothy chapter
2,
um 1 Peter chapter 2, Genesis chapter
35.
Uh the church discourages when God made
Adam and Eve they had nothing on them.
Nothing at all.
And so when your baby is born, don't
bore a hole in the ear. Leave that hole
alone. That's what the child is born
with. Don't stick a hole in here. If God
wanted a hole here, he would have made a
hole there. You you understand me? Oh we
but so we discourage the wearing of
decorative jewelry that really have no
practical function other than to display
yourself. Uh when Adam and Eve sinned,
the first thing they made that the Bible
records made by any human being were the
aprons of leaves
to cover the outside, to make the
outside look nice. And up to this day,
we still focus more on making the
outside look nice than taking care of
the inside. But 1 Peter 3 tells us God
is more concerned with how the inside
looks than how the outside looks. So we
generally discourage the wearing of
decorative jewelry. All right, this
This one comes from an online member.
>> Mhm. They ask,
"Can you explain where the when the
Bible says that God destroyed the world
by flood and only Noah and his family
was saved, then how was the world
repopulated if By Noah and his family.
Pastor By Noah and his family. Noah had
three sons, three wives, Noah's wife,
and Noah's son. And Noah, his wife,
three boys, three wives. They had
children, children married children.
That's the only way it could have
happened.
There was no one else on the earth.
Isn't that something we don't like to
talk about? No, we don't do that now
because with the development over the
years and the the decline of the human
body, it is dangerous to intermarry
within families, but back then God
excused it because that's the only way.
When Adam and Eve were made, they had
children
and the the sons married the daughters.
So we read in Genesis chapter 5 verse uh
5 and all the days of Adam were 8930
years and he died, but he had sons and
daughters.
So they married each other. After a
while, God no longer allowed that to
happen.
But there weren't other people on the
earth.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay. Now this one comes from an from
someone in the audience. They ask,
"If past It says, can the tithes, you
know, the tithes, can can the tithes be
used to pay Bible workers? And should it
also be used for the widows and elderly
amongst the congregation who do not have
any means to supply their needs?"
The tithe is holy.
In the Bible, the tithe was for the
support of the Levites
chiefly
because when
the Israelites
worshipped the golden calf
and Moses came down, he was angry.
He said, "Who's on the Lord's side?"
The Levites came.
God chose the Levites to manage the
tabernacle, the temple, but also in
Genesis 34, Levi
I think and Simeon, they
took part in a murder of an entire city.
They killed all the men.
The prince of the city raped their
sister Dinah. Jacob had 12 boys and one
girl.
Dinah was raped by the prince of the
city. Well, when you have 12 brothers,
you know, it's a dangerous thing to mess
with a girl who has 12 brothers. So the
brothers went to the prince and said,
"Look,
you defiled our sister.
What's your intention?" The prince
really loved her.
He said, "I want to marry her." They
said, "Well, she can't marry an
uncircumcised person."
He said, "We'll all get circumcised."
So Simeon and and Levi and their
servants came, circumcised all the men.
Well, the men will understand what I'm
about to say. After 3 days, the men
couldn't move.
>> [laughter]
>> Then Simeon and Levi and their servants
came and killed all the men
and enslaved the women,
took their cows, their cattle,
everything.
And then God told Jacob, "Leave the
area."
Because Levi was involved in that,
he was not allowed to have land when the
I the Israelites came into Canaan. He
was not given land, but that turned out
to be a blessing because there were
Levites all over the land who could
teach the law of God. And because they
had no land, no possession, the tithe
was set aside to sustain them. And the
Levites represent the ministry and those
who take care of God's church. Now I'd
have to consult the manual to see what
other groups are included, whether
teachers or Bible workers. I think Bible
workers may be included because they're
part of the gospel.
But I'm not speaking with precision on
that point. I'd have to check the church
manual. But generally, the tithe is
sacred.
You don't use it to pay bills
or school fees
or dowry.
It's for God.
All right, we have a question from
someone in the audience.
>> Yes. It's Yes, Pastor.
Uh we recognize that in Revelation
chapter 12, it speaks about a remnant.
Yes. And we recognize that the remnant
is within the Seventh-day Adventist
Church.
What would you say to a member from a
different church who are now the church
is now keeping Saturday as the Sabbath?
>> Mhm. And they also say because of those
two identifying marks, the keeping of
the commandments and having the
testimony of Jesus Christ, the spirit of
prophecy, they claim that they have
that. What would you say to them
concerning their belief that their
body is the remnant church? Well, God
doesn't have two remnants. God has one.
The remnant of God is identified by
the commandments of God
and the spirit of prophecy.
You understand? Now, churches have
claimed to have prophets, but they could
not prove that.
The woman we regard as a prophet in our
church, a prophetess,
she was tested and tried by medical
doctors because one of the things about
a prophet, when he or she's in vision,
that person does not breathe.
And when Ellen White was in vision,
medical staff were around to examine her
and for a couple of hours, she did not
breathe at all. A prophet in vision does
not breathe. She was examined by
doctors. She was not breathing for about
one or one or two hours. I don't recall
the length of time. You stop breathing
for 2 3 minutes, you're dead. She went
on and on not breathing while she was in
vision.
When she came out of vision, she would
take some deep breaths, deep breaths to
re-energize the body. And so she's been
tested. Ellen White has made predictions
that found were found to be true decades
later.
Both in science and in other areas, she
was the first one to mention that the
body functions by electrical impulses.
That had never been discovered until
afterwards scientists discovered that
the body does indeed function by
electrical impulses for the beating of
the heart and other mechanisms. And so
our prophet has been tested. Ellen White
saw events before they actually took
place. In a vision, she saw a meeting,
she saw a man
about 2 years before she met him.
Then she went to Europe, was in a
meeting, and she saw the man and she
told him exactly what she'd seen. So
that woman was indeed an instrument of
God. And so the church can claim her as
one of his signs along with the Sabbath
and the faith of Jesus Christ. Any
church can jump up and say, "The Mormons
say they have a prophet, Joseph Smith.
The Jehovah's Witnesses say they have a
prophet." You look at what they taught.
Any prophet who teaches contrary to the
law of God is a false prophet.
Mhm.
All right.
By the way, the law of God is the test
for every doctrine.
Next question.
>> Let No, let me stay on that for a
minute. All right. The law of God.
Go to 1 Timothy chapter 1.
I see your hand, my lovely little
sister. I see your hand. I see your
hand. 1 Timothy 1.
Let's read from verse 8.
Now you really have to think about the
passage I'm about to show you. You
really have to think. I hope our online
friends are still with us. 1 Timothy
chapter 1, reading from verse 8.
Oh, it's up there. But we know that the
law is good if a man use it lawfully.
Next verse. Knowing this, that the law
what? is not is not made for righteous
man, but for the lawless and
disobedient, for the ungodly and for
sinners, for unholy and profane, for
murderers of fathers and murderers of
mothers, for manslayers, for
whoremongers, for them that defile
themselves with mankind, for
menstealers, for liars, for perjured
persons. Now, listen carefully. And if
there be any other thing
any other thing beside what?
sound
No, no, no. Any other thing beside what?
Listen again.
Go back to 9.
Concentrate.
I will always insist you concentrate.
Listen again.
The law is not made for righteous man,
but for the lawless and disobedient, for
the ungodly and for sinners, for unholy
and profane, for murderers of fathers
and murderers of mothers, for
manslayers, for whoremongers, for them
that defile themselves with mankind, for
menstealers, for liars, for perjured
persons. And if there be any other any
other what?
Sin
beside that list.
Tell me you see that.
Here's an example.
Banana,
custard apple, is that what someone give
me custard apple? Is it custard
banana,
custard apple, pear,
plum, piece of sugar cane, and if there
be any other fruit. Yes.
I'm losing weight up here.
>> [laughter]
>> Focus. Focus. Focus. Listen again.
The law was not made for the righteous
man, but for the lawless and Now, count
how many, okay? Lawless and disobedient,
for the ungodly and for sinners, for
unholy and profane, for murderers of
fathers and murderers of mothers, for
manslayers, for whoremongers, for them
that defy those that defy themselves
with mankind, for menstealers, for
liars, for perjured persons. How many?
And everything else. Now, whether 14 or
10,
if there's anything else beside that,
which is contrary, come on, to sound
doctrine. to sound doctrine.
All of those things then
are contrary, come on, to sound
doctrine. to sound doctrine.
But what are all those things?
Sin. What is sin?
Yes. Anything
that undermine God's law
is contrary, come on, to sound doctrine.
Yeah, you didn't get it.
I need some coconut water.
I love coconut water, by the way. Oh, I
love it so much. God I God has blessed
me. I've been drinking coconut water as
though it's going out of style. Anyway,
if there's any other sin which is
contrary to sound doctrine, anything
opposed to God's law is contrary to
sound doctrine, which means the law is
the test.
Any teaching that undermines God's law
is wrong
and dangerous.
Are you with me?
So, Ellen White said, "The standard
which is to test every doctrine, every
theory, every profession is the law of
God."
And in this modern world, we preach a
gospel that dismisses the law of God.
We preach a gospel that says, "Once
saved, always saved."
We preach a gospel that says, "Jesus
doesn't mind how you live, just so give
your life to him, and that's fine." No,
anything that weakens the law of God is
not sound doctrine. All right, next
question.
Question is
Oh, my little sister had a question.
Give her a mic.
That works.
Oh oh okay. All right. We'll come back
to you, my lovely darling. We'll come
back to you. All right. The question is
you don't worry. Don't worry.
Yes. Many people discredit the church
because the Bible has a text that says,
um, "If you are truly God, you will hold
serpents, you will drink deadly things,"
and the list goes on.
So, because we do not stand on the
pulpit and perform miracles every
Sabbath, they say the church is not the
true church or it is not the church of
God. Okay. Mhm. Mhm. [clears throat]
John the Baptist never performed one
miracle.
So, he was not part of the church of
God?
John the Baptist did not perform one
miracle.
And Jesus said, "Of men born of men
women, John the Baptist was the
greatest."
He performed no miracles.
Keep in mind, the devil can perform
miracles.
A miracle is no proof God is present.
Remember when Moses and Aaron went to
Pharaoh?
When they first began doing their
remarkable things, they threw down their
rod, the Egyptians did the same thing.
What looked like the same thing, anyway.
Up to a point, then they could go no
further. Satan, the Bible says, will
perform miracles in these last days.
Second Thessalonians chapter 2, reading
verse 9, "Whose coming is after the
working of Satan with all power and
signs and lying wonders." Lying wonders
mean his miracles are designed to
deceive, but they are genuine.
Let me ask you this.
All the sores and boils that Job had,
were they genuine?
You're taking so long to answer me.
Remember Job?
He was covered with sores and boils.
Were they real?
Who put them on him? Satan. And he can
take them off.
Luke chapter 13, there was a woman bent
over for 18 years. Jesus said the devil
had her that way.
He can put it on you. He can take it
off.
In the last days, he will heal people
miraculously, and they will think,
"There's Jesus."
The only proof God is present is
"Thus saith the Lord."
And Satan can't copy this.
He hates the word of God.
I'll tell you why.
Satan was a good angel called
Lucifer.
All angels were made by the word of God.
You're saying amen because you're nice.
Go to Psalm 148.
Psalm 148, then we come to my little
angel right here. Psalm 148, we read 1,
2, and 5. I just said all angels were
made by the word of God. Do you have
Psalm 148?
Let's read from verse 1. What does that
say? "Praise ye the Lord. Praise ye the
Lord from the heavens. Praise him in the
heights. Praise ye him, all his angels.
Praise ye him, all his host." Verse 5,
"Praise Let them praise the name of the
Lord, for he commanded and they were
created." Angels were made. God just
said, "Angels, come."
And angels came.
Including Lucifer.
Now,
if angels were made by the word,
here's an angel,
here's the word.
Who made who?
No, don't
Let them talk to me.
Here's an angel,
here's the word. Who made whom?
The word, come on.
So, which is more powerful?
Yes.
Now, Satan knows he was originally made
by the word.
And the word is more powerful than he
is.
So, when you go to the word, there's
nothing he can do.
So, when he came to tempt Christ, Christ
said,
"It's written."
Then he switched temptations, Christ
said, "It's written."
said, "It's written." He never changed
his response, because this is the way.
Matthew 8:16, "And when the even was
come, they brought unto him many that
were possessed with devils, and he cast
out the spirit with his word."
Yes, my little friend right here now.
See what this question is.
Hello.
Is it wrong to wear jewelry? Yes, well,
the church discourages it.
Yeah, we as a church, we say, "No, don't
wear it," because there's no real need
for it.
Now, the church says decorative jewelry,
just to decorate yourself. We don't
include a watch
that has a specific function.
But just to wear jewelry, to wear
jewelry, the church says no.
Okay.
All right. Pastor, we have an online
question that is going to bounce right
off of that. It says, "Are God's remnant
people to wear jewelry and the wedding
band?" Well, I have Now, the wedding
band is a little controversial. The
church does not oppose the wedding band.
Are you with me?
Now, the church urges us, "Don't go to
extra expense just to buy a little band
of gold."
Ellen White also says the same thing,
but she also says, "In those countries
where a wedding band is an established
part of the culture,
then fine."
But don't split the church over a
wedding band
while people are working on Sabbath or
you're following me and not returning a
tithe, and you're breaking up a church
over a wedding band. Wait a minute.
Jesus said, "There are some weightier
matters of the law."
And so, the church does not condemn the
wedding band, but Ellen White
discourages it generally, but she does
say, "In those places where it is an
established, entrenched part of the
culture, then there's no problem." But
generally, she says, "Don't spend money
on a wedding band. Put a ring around
your heart. That will keep you
faithful."
This never keeps anybody faithful.
What's that?
Oh, they take it off and then they
evangelize. Okay. All right. Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> All right. Next question. This This
comes from another online member.
It says, "Does God answer our prayers
immediately or does it take a long time?
And what happens when God doesn't answer
or why?"
>> It can be either way. It can be either
way. It's entirely up to God.
When we pray, we're not demanding that
God do anything.
We're making requests according to his
will.
God can answer immediately if he sees
that's best for his glory and for you,
or he may take a while.
Case in point, when Abraham came into
Canaan, he was 75 years old. He prayed
for a child, he got that child when he
was 100.
How long did he pray? 25 years for a
child. Now, I'm not saying we all have
to pray 25 years. His son, Isaac,
married Rebecca. Rebecca was barren. He
prayed 20 years for a child. He and
Rebecca got married when he was 40.
Rebecca had that child when he was 60.
So they prayed and prayed and prayed.
But there are other things that God did
does immediately. For instance, Elijah
prayed and said, "Lord, open his eyes."
And God opened the man's eyes
immediately and he saw
chariots with angels surrounding the
house where Elijah lived. And so it's
entirely up to God whether he'll answer
immediately or take a while. If he takes
a while, keep praying. Sometimes God
doesn't answer because we stop praying
too soon.
We stop praying too soon. How many times
did Jesus pray, "Father, if thou be
willing, remove this cup?" Three times.
Some people say, "Well, if God knows
what I want, why do I have to pray?"
Because praying is fellowship with God.
You don't just pray to ask God for
things. God's not an ATM. You know what
I mean by an ATM? He's not an ATM. He
wants fellowship.
And if he delays to answer, he just
wants you to keep coming back to talk to
him.
The moment he answers, you're gone.
Don't look so guilty. Okay. But what
should they do when God doesn't answer
their prayer? Well, then you accept
God's will. No.
By the way, when you ask for something,
you should be able to answer two
questions.
If God gives me this, is this for his
glory?
And how will other people be blessed?
Let me say it again.
Well, let me say it by giving a
quotation. Historical Sketches, page
285, paragraph 4. Ellen White wrote,
"Every youth should be impressed with
the fact that he's not his own. His
strength, his time, his talents belong
to God. It should be his chief purpose
in life to glorify God and do good to
his fellow man. We have two motivations,
love to God, love to your fellow man.
You say, 'Father, I want to move to
Nicaragua. How will that glorify me?'"
Or be a blessing to others.
Those two questions must be answered. If
you cannot answer them, don't move.
Father, I want to marry that man. How
will that glorify me?
We must learn to think of God first.
Isaiah 43:7, "I have created him for my
glory, not to his."
It's a strange way to think, but that's
how Jesus lived. John 8:29, "And he that
have sent me is with me. The Father hath
not left me alone, for I do always those
things that please him." When you live
like that, you live a powerful life.
But that calls for the crucifixion of
self.
Next question. Yes, and I'm being told
that This brother said 100 more
questions. He wasn't joking. I know he
told me this is our final question that
they want to throw to the audience. This
is what they're taking our final
question.
>> Final question.
Yes, there's a gentleman right there.
Give him a mic.
Ooh.
Yes, my good brother.
Is Pastor, um, good evening. Is there,
um, Good evening. My question was, um, I
had it for a long while. Um, I read um
in in Daniel chapter, um, 9, chapter 2,
um, verse 20, talking about, um, what do
you call it, um,
the 70 week prophecy. I read and I I
tried and I studied I tried to Google it
and I still don't get no, um,
no answer to the Is there the what?
the 70 week prophecy in Dan in Daniel.
The what? 70 week prophecy. 70 week
prophecy, uh-huh. What about it? Can I
explain? Oh, that'll take too long.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, that'll take too long.
>> Serious? Yeah, yeah, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yeah. It'll take too long. All right.
Well, what what
>> Yeah, get the book. Uh-huh. There's
several books you you can go online and
read them actually. A book like Daniel
and Revelation
will explain the 70 week prophecy,
Daniel 9:25 to 27, I think it is. Yeah,
you get a book and study that, but
that'll take a while. Mhm.
And if I were to try to do it quickly,
it'd go over people's heads. So that
would be doing a disservice to the
passage in scripture.
But we ought to understand that passage.
I'm glad you said that. We ought to
understand that passage. It's part of
the 2300 day prophecy which ends in
October 22, 1844. By the way, only
Adventists really in this modern world
can explain that prophecy.
All right, you said that was the last
one. Well, apparently You didn't tell
the truth. No, I did tell the truth, but
just as soon as I said that, someone
already sent in a question.
>> boss, you can cut it off. That's why
that's why I asked my boss. No, the real
owner did okay. You asked your boss,
okay, then the case is closed. Okay.
What's the question? All right, this is
there two questions, they said.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. This one is This one is a trick.
It says, "Should the
Should the church, when they do, you
know, when they're on church and they
ask members to participate, should they
use members on the pulpit that use
makeup and dress inappropriately?"
>> No.
No, case closed. No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Say it again, Pastor. That pulpit is
a sacred place.
You can't let every Tom, Dick, Harry,
and Jezebel come up. They're no, no, no,
no. Mhm.
If you're a lawyer and you go to before
a judge to argue a case,
you have to dress a certain way or he
will ask you to leave his court.
If an earthly judge requires respect by
the way you dress, the God of heaven and
earth because Mhm. You want to dress any
way you like, stay in the pew.
The back pew. Yes, go ahead.
What's inappropriate? Tell me. Well,
their their examples were Uh-huh.
You know,
thin strap for females, if they were
wearing nail polish, if they were
showing a bit of cleavage.
>> no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Yes,
don't squash that. Let's move on. When a
woman dresses, uh, don't kill me,
especially when a woman dresses, she
must take into consideration the effect
on a man.
Men are affected by sight, mainly.
That's why prostitutes dress the way
they dress in most Western countries.
You have to be careful the effect you
may have on a man. Men must also be
careful how they dress. Yes.
>> [laughter]
>> You are
If you read the epistles of Paul, all
Paul's counsel about dress are directed
to women.
And he was led by the Holy Spirit.
All his counsel on dress in Timothy and
Timothy and then Peter's counsel are
directed to the sisters.
I'll leave it at that. Yes.
This one This one comes from a pastor. A
pastor, okay. Well, I guess it's from
someone who sent the message. It says,
"An SDA husband
told his wife that he was divorcing her
and the divorce was between
you know, her, the husband, and God.
Is there a biblical position for a man
to take up that position to say it's not
just between me and you, it's me, you,
and God?" No, you You divorce your wife
if there's adultery.
And even then, you don't have to
divorce.
Because the cross of Calvary tells us
God loves reconciliation. Are you with
me? So the fact that you have cause does
not mean you should divorce. But a
divorce is not just you and God, it is
you, the person, and God. And there must
be a biblical ground for divorce. If
there's no biblical ground, depending on
how severe the situation is, you may
separate.
But separation is not divorce.
And you can't get involved with anyone
else while you're separated. The
separation may be to give some time
together to fix the problem.
Marriage is a serious thing.
Once you're in it, you're in it.
We must resist this earthly approach to
marriage. I jump in, the water's too
hot, I jump out. That's not the way it
works. When you jump in, stay in.
Are you following me or don't jump in at
all.
Mhm.
You said say it again, but you got it.
My boss added me two more questions.
Okay.
Yes.
Uh,
>> [clears throat]
>> well, he said this is supposed It says,
"When God comes again for the second
time, will he come for the only Will he
come only for educated people?"
Who sent that question?
Wait, cuz they had a They had a
follow-up question. It says, "Can people
who are uneducated still work for the
Lord?"
The disciples were not educated.
The only educated disciple was Judas.
And I won't elaborate on that. The only
educated disciple
was Judas.
Now, of course, we had Oh, he was the
most educated. We have the Apostle Paul,
very educated man. Look how God used
him. God will save all those who put
their trust in him.
You are not saved by degrees or lack of
degrees or houses or lands. Have you put
your trust in the Savior? If the answer
is yes, when he comes, you're going home
with him.
Is that it? No one sent me any message.
No one gave me a slip of paper. Turn off
the phone quickly.
>> [laughter]
>> Pastor, I must say thank you so much for
taking the time out for this Q&A. I
believe everyone who was here were
blessed. I hope that you guys had some
of your questions answered. And if you
did not, just have to wait till they
come back some other time.
When that will be, only God knows. When
does sunset?
When does the sunset? They have long
time before the sunset. All right. Let
me say a prayer. Father,
we thank you for the question and answer
session. I hope we said something that
enlightened somebody.
As I go into this brief section now, be
with us, I pray, in Jesus' name. Amen.
What's your favorite Bible verse?
Somebody raise a hand.
What is it?
Say it.
Say it. Say it.
Why is that your favorite verse?
Uh-huh.
Okay. All right.
Keep it with you, don't lose it.
Somebody else, what's your favorite
Bible verse?
Come on, I don't see enough Yes.
Matthew what?
What does it say?
Why is that your favorite verse?
You need to be a light. All right,
somebody else.
What's your favorite Bible verse? Yes.
Uh-huh.
Why?
Uh-huh. Why is that your favorite verse?
Yes, he will.
He never fails us. Did I hear someone to
the left? Yes.
What what?
Yes.
Uh-huh.
Those who are in Christ Jesus, who walk
not after the flesh, but after the
spirit. A very good, verse. Right in the
middle of the gospel. Somebody Yes.
What?
Uh-huh.
Why is that your favorite verse?
Yes, they do. Yes, they do. All right.
Thank you, my brother. Anybody else,
what's your favorite verse?
Oh, yes.
Psalm 119:105. Mhm.
Why?
Uh-huh.
Yes, and that is the Bible Yes, yes.
Lamp unto my feet, light to my path. It
shows you how to go. Somebody else,
what's your favorite Yes.
Yes.
Uh-huh. Mhm.
I would have Yes.
Mhm.
Uh-huh.
Amen. Where's that found?
Amen, sister. Why do you like it?
Yes, yes, yes.
I hope to be there with you. All right.
Somebody else, what's your favorite
verse? Yes.
Galatians 5:1.
Say it again.
Stand fast therefore in the liberty
wherewith Christ has made us free, and
be not entangled again with the yoke of
bondage. All right. Sorry for rattling
that off like that. Some Why is that
your favorite verse?
Because what?
Okay, okay, okay, okay. And God has made
you free.
Ah, God bless you. God bless you. God
bless you. Yes.
Yes?
What verse is that?
Oh, Jeremiah's Yes, call unto me and I
will answer thee, and show thee great
and mighty things which thou knowest
not.
All right, sister, thank you. Yes, he is
faithful to his word. That's why God is
so dependable. He's a righteous God. He
is faithful because he always keeps his
word. Always. If God says, "I'm coming
to see you," a hurricane will not
prevent him, or flood, or an earthquake.
He's coming. They may prevent us, but
not God. There is no circumstance that
can prevent God from keeping his word,
not even death.
Did God promise Abraham he'd have the
land of Canaan? Yes or no?
Did Abraham get it?
No.
Hebrews 11:13. These all died in faith,
not having received the promise. Abraham
died without having possessed Canaan,
but it was promised.
God has to wake Abraham up to fulfill
his promise.
You're not following me.
If for no other reason, Jesus Christ
must come back to keep his word to
Abraham, because he told him, "I'll give
you this land."
And Romans chapter 4:13 tells us that
when God said that, what he meant was
Abraham would inherit inherit the entire
world.
So, Jesus must come back, wake Abraham
up, and give him the world as he
promised. So, not even death can keep
God from fulfilling his word. Somebody
else, what's your favorite verse?
Yes.
Uh-huh.
Why do you like that?
Yes, he is.
It says, "O taste and see." God invites
us to prove him. O taste and see
that the Lord is good. In Psalm in
Malachi 3:10, "Prove me now herewith."
The only God that does that. The other
gods don't do that. Only God tells his
people, "Prove me. Put me to the test,
and I'll come through." Somebody else,
what's your favorite verse?
Where? Where? Where? Oh, yes.
Uh-huh.
Kindreds and tongue and people. Mhm.
Yes. Uh-huh.
His judgment has come.
Come. Mhm. And worship him.
Yes. First angel's message. Why do you
like that?
Yes.
Mhm.
That's right. That's right.
Okay.
All right, my brother, thank you very
much. All right. Anybody else? Yes, my
little angel. What's your verse?
Genesis 1:1.
Why is that your favorite verse?
It shows God can do anything. Genesis
1:1. Can I tell you something?
That is also my favorite verse in the
Bible. Genesis 1:1. In the beginning,
God created the heaven and the earth. It
explains the origin
of life.
Where the life came from. It gives us
heaven, that's space. Earth, that's
matter. Beginning, that's time.
My favorite verse, Genesis
1:1. In the beginning, God created the
heaven and the earth. Well, let me end
it right there. My brothers and sisters,
may the Lord bless your lives.
May the Lord doubly bless your children.
Whatever you do, as surely as God lives,
be faithful to God.
Obey God.
God does not bless disobedience.
God does not bless doubt.
God cannot bless sin.
If there's something in your life you're
doing,
you know it is contrary to God's word,
stop it. But confess to God. Tell God
you're sorry.
He holds no grudges.
You'll put a smile on his face. Tell him
you're sorry.
He'll forgive you, and he'll enable you
to put your path your
in the right path. Sin is the only
reason why God cannot bless his church.
And so, as your brother in Christ, I
urge you, if there's any area in your
life that is contrary to God's will, get
it right with the help of God's spirit,
so that you can be a light reflecting
the glory of God.
And when he comes, may the Lord save all
of you.
I mean all of you into his kingdom with
all your children,
with all your relatives, and may God go
after your relatives who are not in the
truth, and bring them in before it is
too late. May God provide all your
needs, whatever they may be. May God
touch your bodies and ease your aches
and your pains. May God protect your
homes from burglars and thieves. May God
protect you as you drive on the
dangerous highway. And above all, may
God keep you faithful unto death.
God bless you. If ever I come across
your mind, wherever you are, all I want
you to say is, "Lord, wherever that man
is, put your words in his mouth." I love
you for loving Jesus. God bless you. If
we don't meet here, let's meet on the
sea of glass.
Let me thank the ladies who cooked.
And I really mean that. And their
husbands who allowed them to cook.
Ladies,
Sister Tan and Sister Michelle, thank
[snorts] you. Thank you. Thank you. I
mean that from my heart. Thank you very
much. Not only for the good food, but
the lovely attitude with which you did
it. May the Lord make your homes his
residence. May the angels always be your
security guards to go with you wherever
you go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
My young brother who came for me quite
often, I don't see him.
Where is he?
Jared, okay. Well, Oh, there he is.
Thank you so much. Thank you so much.
The family that housed me in my palace,
their basement palace. Thank you very
much. I don't think I broke anything.
So, thank you. God bless you. I really
mean that. I think I told you so last
week. When people house me, I pray for
them rest of my life.
I present them to God. I present them to
God. So, thank you. Thank you, pastor.
Thanks for trusting me to occupy this
desk night after night. I really mean
that. May the Lord bless you beyond your
imagination. May he bless your children.
May he put a diadem on the wife of your
head as a queen of the home. And may he
save your entire family when he comes.
And may he take you higher and higher
until he comes to take you home. Brother
Ray, whom I've known for 200 years.
Brother Ray, God bless you. God bless
you. Bless you. Bless you. Brother Ray,
I've known Ray for a long time. Known
his wife even longer. So, you have a man
who's committed to putting the gospel
online.
The man who does not play. He really is
committed to this. Now, I'm not saying
that because he's standing here. I'm
telling you what I have seen over the
decade. Whoever contributed to this
experience, thank you. I will leave with
no regrets whatsoever, not even for the
heat. I
Amen, pastor. Amen. Because you have to
be alive to feel hot. Are you with me?
So, I thank God I am alive to feel hot.
In Michigan, when it's freezing, I thank
God I'm alive to freeze to death. So,
thank you very much and God bless you.